yeah this woman woman loved to talk and
lack attention and i just won my
attention and she loved it
so i have another question do you think
women like being objectified absolutely
absolutely
some of them
i think yeah there is not all of them
yes it's definitely not all of them i
think it's a sense of yeah going back to
that attention thing if they are craving
that attention
there are times when they want it
i think actually does this i asked the
girl this actually one time and she said
she likes to to be objectified or or
receive attention from the guy she likes
yeah yeah
yeah the men she doesn't like i don't
want it she yeah i don't need it they're
creeps and there you know really i
appreciate all compliments
[Laughter]
i don't know why
i don't get a legit though like one day
i'm just saying one day you're going to
be 55 no one's going to be complimenting
you
i'm going to be a milf
are men lined up to date 55 year olds
what about guys that love milfs like
there's definitely guys up there that
love an old woman yeah okay do you guys
like do you guys want to date a 55 year
old no you
i'll sleep with a 55 year old depending
on the situation
but i wouldn't stand here and be like
yeah that's what i'm looking for what
about if she's bath
yeah i'll smash yeah but you wouldn't
like okay someone who's someone that's
like i don't know jennifer aniston buff
yeah but
those are so lovely
spicy okay but
you're looking for the exception like
that's like the one like those are those
are celebrities those are celebrities do
you have celebrity money to maintain
that stuff no
okay there's plenty of people
that look good okay do you think the
average 55 year old woman yeah men are
lined up to date her
i don't know it's a quick note
this is what you're overlooking right a
50 year old woman will not bring you
peace oh why
because she's going to call a baggage
so are you
what makes you think that you've got
baggage in peace though right
how do you know she doesn't want peace
woman no woman don't want peace emotions
they want trouble always
always i don't want peace i want
problems yeah boy i don't like peace
nice guys they're like trouble i mean
why do you think women are always
talking about men are trash because
they're sleeping with the trash man
but i feel ugh i feel like it's like a
celeb oh every girl has a toxic
ex-boyfriend
i feel like do you have a toxic
ex-boyfriend ah we all do
that's what i'm saying
but but you never used to play games
right
but do you know what i think it is i
think every girl and i'm not like i'm
not saying that every girl was a nice
girl but i feel like every girl goes
through that stage of having that toxic
boyfriend
and they'll either grow out of it
they'll go that was a [ __ ] scenario i
will never do that again and they learn
from that and they
go to someone that's better
or they can continually perpetuate that
same relationship over and over again so
i feel like sometimes if you're a nice
person sometimes you attract that toxic
person because they're like
go ahead i don't have a toxic boyfriend
because i just can't deal an ex we're
talking about not currently no like ex
never yeah yeah first boyfriend
is it because i'm just like
so cute i just really don't i can't
stand like stupidity
i really can't like it doesn't make
sense like i had a guy that i was dating
like he blocked me and i just dropped it
because it was just dumb like i don't
would you say that you would you say
you're the exception more than the role
yeah for sure
yeah yeah i have no patience because i
just feel like what's the point if
you're not going to end up together yeah
how did you develop
that value system to not have to not
tolerate you know a toxic guy
you have a good family did you have a
good example
no it's more like i had bad experiences
with friends and then i took that into
romantic relationships as well
okay but you had toxic friends so
essentially you had like
a similar
toxic friends dropped it learned from it
never had a bad really yeah i would
argue it's your culture though i think a
lot of asian women in asia the dating
game is a bit different because they
they value
intelligence a bit more and more like um
blue blue color kind of things i don't
really see many like i had a chinese
girlfriend a thai girlfriend they don't
really go for bad boys they want the guy
who got a job at google
that's who they that's who they talk
about in uni she's like oh that's so
serious
no it's true they don't bash men either
yeah they don't get the whole feminism
thing actually if i had like a bad
boyfriend my mom would like
not give me a break and my dad would
think i'm dumb
like i don't want my parents to think
yeah that's like i feel like everything
in dating is your own fault yeah
absolutely
so if um if women always say they don't
like to be objectified then why do they
wear makeup
because that's not cute why do you wear
makeup
to look better
yeah
what's like what's the you don't want to
be objectified right no i'm fine with it
no but woman i'm just saying like i like
people finding me attractive i don't
know like i don't i don't want people to
like you know be reposed yeah be like
weird with it but like i think it's like
lying to say you don't wear makeup for
other people at all yeah i think with
you you're obviously being honest about
it whereas a lot of women will be like
we're doing it for us
like i'm doing it for myself for three
hours don't go straight lie to your face
straight up lie to your face
no because if i was home alone i'd look
homeless
so i'm not gonna say i don't look good
for other people
but
other people but like just for men
do you know what i mean is it like most
of the time like i dress up because i
want another girl telling me that like
my outfit's cute not because like i want
a guy to come over to me and like try
and chat to me well it's based on what
guys like
your uncle and women too
and women too question for you right if
you met up in cute outfits with your
friends and you all had makeup yeah what
would you go and do together
chill sure you won't you won't go to
clubbing or see any other guys you just
you just wear cute outfits and make up
just uh just to chill out and girl lolly
parties
and what and go on
do you know what yeah i'm so sick of
voice saying this because girls get
dressed and go to dinner together girls
get dressed and go and chill where men
can check them out because it's funny
because come on you're telling me you're
telling me at a girls night where you're
drinking wine and you're at the house
you're not leaving the house at all yeah
that women get dressed up the same than
if they're going to a club yeah
who do you hang around
like people people dress different when
more eyes are on them
so you're telling me you're telling me
in
seriously i'm telling you i'm honestly
all seriously your friends your friends
go go to your apartment to hang out and
wear the same thing they would wear to a
club
i mean we're not like we're not in like
stilettos but we're like we're dressed
nice we've got our hair done we've got
our makeup done we're having dinner
like a cap i don't know why i don't know
i'm not that i'm not gonna go i'm not
gonna go to dinner at my girl's house
pictures
but you dress up right yeah dress up
your word dress and you wear makeup yeah
what for your girlfriend yeah no come on
stop it why not no [ __ ]
are you one of those women like like you
you don't you think it doesn't mean
anything if someone like pays for you or
something like that what do you mean
well i i have my own money so i don't
need you to pay for me
yeah i i work
but what's an independent woman yeah
kind of thing
um
yeah i guess i think like i've just
always been raised
to be able to pay my own way like if my
boyfriend wants to pay for something
then obviously i'll offer but if he says
no no it's on me then cool but like i
don't need anyone to pay anything for me
like i can pay for myself so do you know
um behind makeup like there's biological
reasons that we wear them so
yeah so it's like so how can we say it's
not for other people when you're
signaling sexual arousal i've heard this
i don't know where that like is that
what it like yeah because it's like
during sex your lips are red that's why
there's red lipstick and it's like it's
same with yeah blush on the cheeks